hey 42 here in 1789 Benjamin Franklin
wrote a letter to French physicist John
Baptist Laroy in the letter he wrote our
new constitution is now established and
has an appearance that promises
permanency what in this world nothing
can be said to be certain except death
and taxes and he was correct taxes are a
pain death doubly so mortality is
inevitable it can be prolonged if we eat
enough green foods and do enough squats
or so on mothers tell us what eventually
enters entropy the second law of
thermodynamics states that everything
that is ordered we'll return to disorder
due to engine P our ordered system that
we call life must eventually decay into
chaos and thus desk so what happens when
our time is up and I'm not just talking
about the physical effects of death more
importantly where do we go if anywhere
now there are 4,200 religions in the
world today and all of them have a
slightly different opinion of the
afterlife what in truth only one group
of people actually knows for certain
what happens when you die and that is
the death so let's ask them shall we no
really let's ask them you see there are
a group of people who claim to have died
and then come back to life and they're
not a small group of people in America
alone eight million people claim to have
had an nd8 near-death experience many of
whom claims you have passed over to the
other side and experienced something
before being dragged back into the real
world again so what did they experience
did they catch a glimpse of what really
awaits us all beyond the grave in 2011 a
man was midway through major surgery but
it went wrong and he quickly bled out he
was declared dead
minutes amazingly the surgeons managed
to revive him he described his minutes
in the afterlife
like so I woke up in what looks like
space but there weren't any stars or
white
I wasn't floating so to speak I was just
there he also said that he felt nothing
he wasn't hungry tired cold or hot he
just felt peace I knew there was light
and love somewhere nearby but I had no
heard your need to go to it right away
he quoted another case tells of a
college students who overdosed on
sleeping pills in his dorm room
paramedics came quickly but during the
ambulance ride he was clinically
declared dead for three minutes when he
awoke he described seeing his own
unconscious body inside the ambulance
and he witnessed himself
flatline was he actually seeing his own
body of the spirit or was it just an
unconscious hallucination amazingly the
patient was able to accurately describe
the paramedic inside the ambulance and
he could even recall her name despite
not physically seeing her before or
after he fell unconscious a similar
story of an out-of-body experience comes
from a boy who went eight years old
drowned at his local swimming pool in
the deep end
he suddenly awoke stood at the opposite
end of the pool where he witnessed two
lifeguards pulling his non-responsive
body out of the water he saw them
attempt CPR for five minutes on his own
body without any success
he watched himself get put onto a
stretcher and followed himself onboard
the ambulance all the way to the
hospital
whilst on board the ambulance he started
to feel a warm motherly presence urging
him to wake up and after a few seconds
he had returned to his body and was
brought back into the real world
he noted that waking up from his death
we state felt like being shot through a
cannon at the swimming pool where he
drowned and landing inside the ambulance
several streets away
there are thousands of these stories
from around the globe and everyone
experiences something slightly different
so researchers compiled a list of the
most common experiences people claims
you have felt when declared clinically
dead and then brought back to life most
people feel a rapid transit inside a
London dark tunnel many have an
out-of-body experience where they can
see their own body usually from some
distance away although their body has
slightly different characteristics to
what they knew during their lifetime and
appears to be very different in nature
somehow they witness every attempt being
made on their physical body to bring
them back to life
they often sense warm presence or meet
their relatives who urge them to return
to the world of the living
there is usually a boundary that
represents the border between life and
whatever is beyond life that seems to
draw closer and closer so many people
have an out-of-body experience
but not everyone many people experience
a deep intense blackness or slip into a
strange over dimensional void where they
no longer feel anything but are still
aware of themselves or vostell are being
able to see time as a physical object
that they can browse through or even
manipulate as if their whole life is
pages in a book that they can flick
through it will so there we go
surely all these thousands of stories of
some kind of afterlife is well proof
that there is something beyond what we
know hmm
unfortunately we shouldn't be so hasty
to make that call through his research
dr. Rick Strassman believed that all
these near-death experiences are
actually fictitious hallucinations in
the brain
caused by a psychedelic drug called D
and T now DMT has a long history of
making people see things that aren't
really there
Amazonian tribes have been taking a
natural home-brewed form of DMT called
ayahuasca for hundreds of years as part
of their healing rituals
after death the tissue of the pineal
gland decomposes very quickly
releasing substantial amounts of DMT
around the body
you see DMT is actually produced
naturally inside our bodies in 1993
professional drug taker Terence Mckenna
seriously he made a living by taking
psychedelic drugs and writing about his
experiences says the following about DMT
you cannot imagine a stranger drugged or
a stranger experienced in fact DMT is
the most powerful hallucinogenic drug
there is now if a small amount of DMT
can make you hallucinate that you're
Mexican and you live inside a taco
then I'm fairly confident that it's
powerful enough to make you have an
out-of-body experience during an episode
of temporary mortality the furthermore
research is showing that the events that
are experienced by a person during the
near-death experience are very similar
to what people experience when they take
the MT recreationally still such as
passing through a tunnel and having an
out-of-body experience so then the case
is strong that this naturally-occurring
drug could be responsible understandably
people who have these experiences aren't
usually too pleased with this
explanation because to them it felt so
real
many people fade up their brief
encounters with the afterlife actually
felt more real and tangible than the
real world but then DMT is an
extraordinarily powerful drug it
actually causes us to hallucinate by
actually firing the neurons inside our
brain associated with these particular
visions so in a way these people are
actually seeing these events but what is
seeing in truth our brain is capable of
making us see anything it wants us to
even if it's not really happening in
front of us as well as interpreting the
data entering our brain via our eyes our
brain can also completely make off
visuals and we have no way of telling
apart the real visions from the fake so
it's a good job that most of the time
our
brain playing nicely also we think they
do that is a complicated process it's
not as black and white as you see in the
movies there were actually two stages to
death
the first is clinical death this happens
as soon as the patient stops breathing
and their heart ceases to pump blood
this usually lasts for up to six minutes
during this stage the major organs are
still alive these minutes are crucial
and if a patient can be revived during
these six minutes they can avoid
permanent brain damage
after six minutes however comes the
second stage of death biological sex the
organs begin to shut down and cells
start to degenerate within 12 hours the
skin loses its color and rigor mortis
sets in making the body rigid freezing
it in place this is caused by calcium
leaking into the muscles which causes
them to contract and pencil but
something even stranger happens at the
exact moment of death as was discovered
when dr. Duncan MacDougall conducted a
macabre experiment in Massachusetts on
attempt of April 1901 he gathered six
dying patients somehow and put them onto
specially made beds that were also very
precise weighing scales he observed the
way to be patient very closely at the
exact moment of each of their deaths
what he noticed was up at the exact
moment of death each patient lost 21
grams of weight MacDougall factored in
every offer form and weight loss that
could possibly occur at the moment of
death such as sweat evaporating from the
body and the final breath exiting the
lungs but nothing came close to
accounting for the 21 grams of instant
weight loss MacDougall's only
explanation was that something we
couldn't see had suddenly left the body
could it be the patient's soul does the
human soul weigh
21 grams well we should take
MacDougall's results with a pinch of
salt because his experiments had a few
floors firstly six patients is nowhere
near a large enough sample
group to get a reliable result the
weight loss had also been blown
completely out of proportion
only one of the patients lost 21 grams
three other patients did lose weight was
a different amount and two of the
patients were excluded from the results
completely because of mechanical
failures with the equipment also to
scale something
Duggal were using were only accurate to
six grams anyway so MacDougall's
experiment shouldn't be trusted entirely
but it is certainly interesting
something must have happened at the
point of death to trigger the scale to
alter their readings the experiment
hasn't been repeated since on more
modern equipment because apparently it's
now or never called to pop GLaDOS on a
weighing scale just before she kicks the
bucket modern studies have been
conducted to try and uncover the secrets
of the afterlife although they have
tended to be less practical and
MacDougall's experiments recently the
British teamed up with some Germans and
studied 2,000 cardiac arrest patients
who had been declared clinically dead
and then resuscitated 40% of the
patients reported having a conscious
awareness whilst they were technically
dead many of whom said had an
out-of-body experience and could see
themselves from a third person point of
view of particular interest was a 57
year old man from Southampton who was
able to accurately describe everything
that happened to himself and every
procedure the doctors carried out on his
body after his heart had stopped he
could even recall how many times the
life-support machine beep he apparently
saw everything from the corner of the
room according to the doctors presence
everything he said happened really
happened the scientists involved in the
study have concluded that some of the
patients accounts of what happened
whilst they were clinically dead
we're so frightfully accurate that there
is undisputably life after death and
even went as far as to say that they had
confirmed the existence of some kind of
afterlife others are more
critical and simply blame the patients
experiences on DMT claiming they were
simply hallucinating whilst unconscious
in truth we have no way of knowing for
sure what happens when we're laid to
rest and we will probably never find out
until our time is up but does it really
matter
sure it might be interesting to think
about but spending one's precious time
trying to answer an unanswerable
question is ironically just a waste of
life so if you think about it by
watching this video I've just wasted
several minutes of your life sorry about
that but thanks for watching anyway
[Music]